今日は外れ社長ぞ
佐藤次郎です ba
うわぁいう中で見る始めて初めてなんだけど
あっほんとれた ep きっぺ宿へ進み少しあれなんか声を裏返してどうぞじゃあ
こんな感じでやりそんな女さっき対談した時もっと落ち着いて来よねこんなねこれ貼っ
ちゃうというのが入ったああそうかあるかな
そう僕が
ここ最近の
[音楽]
ブーブーインディアンポーカーん
た
不明
[音楽]
ブーブー言わせ1巻もうちょっとまあそれ
ある青ドンラッキーみたいなそんな若造に負けないよ僕はそう
ちょっと入れててうざいんですけど生きててうざい案も路34今日も343も力後
もしくは君さあ
過ごすことだかそれ論系ちゃってさーこれだって結構な再生帰っていくかもしれないし
あなた流千葉トップバッドプラナーでしょ
なあ
でこんな風に出てくるのかいやもちろん同協定はいいですよね残響てか袋は素晴らしい
ですようんアレですね大衆的でいいということです
の軽いと好学校&ああ三度の飯より広貫堂といったのは屋島の築きましょうなんだよ
さあ書きましょうさあ覚悟って多すぎんか神ちょっとキャラソンちょっと減らすのか
kimi no プロディアなんていう計画する場合も力ゴースですよ
おっおおっっていう
ん
2が抜けないのこれだったらいいはてやすそうだなとかっていうことだよまあねそう
ですよ
[音楽]
強いデーできたので早速-8
びっくりした
っていうなんかそう言って所ねいいねまぁなるすごい youtube あるんでしょ
youtube あっ今津北3ひきますねはいじゃあこれで
これでいきますみーちゃだめよああこれでございますじゃあこれ見ろさあこれ
です
なるほどこれを俺後に貼って大
トンイ
貴様が容易けど要所では
ば打を浴び網を張ったバージョンだーっっ
あの木皆さんあの何があの機能
悪いことを見つ
君が何か言っちょっとこれは俺ちょっと人より悪いなぁと言う
ぜひ佐藤は
なぜいっ
佐藤はグーンとでねー
俺これ当てていい
どうぞ当てたらどっち勝つだか合っちゃってたなぁ
だめです言っちゃダメですよね
でももう分かったら何がしたい方が絶対それは言いますよねはい僕の悪いのはルイマル
イっていうかどうですよねー
カメラバッテリ切れそうだああ
お尻かあー打ち切りはっ
大丈夫がまあ嘘ですけど嘘だのかおっ今でも
ん
もう君の
だから割と道へ用水はない悪いので歩いところにですか
ok と悪いところ3つ出たらしない
また他の動画でも
二ヶ領下6者だっ
用カムよねー
僕が如何かこれを増やし怪しい怪しい見えた見えた見えた見えますよちょっと俺失敗し
たかもしれませんこのゲームの運び方
私はこれ呼び捨てては塗って最初の里はどうも受けては予備せずなーっていう一緒に
なったけどよビスじゃない
俺これ絶対わかるんだよな
から始まったんですね
そう思うでしょエツ子と思うでしょいやそれはそう思うと思ったっていうのが作成のと
したとするを逆手に取っておい年長者だぞ
これ誰に生きてる前執事なぜかんが一筋なう
その一つ犠打は外へ出ないんだけど解説ジンジャー理由
季節だいえーい
が悪いたんですよねえこういやーわかっちゃったという風ななんていうかな指針ぶり新
ぶりで即座に輪っかはこれ春のにありません
ちょっと高く太りますよねドールの命住んでるけどねどもー
入っん
な中顔してるんすや
酒飲みてやっイオンと話したければいいんだよ
そうですよねちなみにあれを
悪いもはにアーマーっ中アホ面してんの
ぶっちゃけはいじゃあこれぞんまあの kazoo
まあ逆にいいと思っ
ではここに入ってないとこまで数したの使い方は
舌の使い方は悪い方だけ書き月
じゃないって言ってるじゃないかたら全然とこそ大事なんだけどそうね覚醒さわりと
思ってるしたは悪いです
シャアも使い方は上手じゃない気がしますね
ん
滑舌ですよねフーズですね動く
君きゅいーだんっていい
あぁそう結構おっしゃってたんだよさっきなんてちょっとふざけたらイヤ気に入って
いうかラーとかならそういうことぐらいと佐藤さんはぱきゅ曲ないんだ
戦いになると冷静ですっはっはっはっに書いていきますこれで僕が始め徐々にはしたい
みんな酔っぱいっ
これを絶対いけると思う
絶対いけると思うんごめん最後に彼等は悪いけど4を買った
これはもう完全にいただきましたいやいやあの子とし片山ドン
しちゃんっ
佐藤次郎で行けるんだよなぁ
この3日間で一番あの
楽しかったことという
うわっ
佐藤03がいたことにまあそう言うとこの3日間で一番
恥ずかしかった
ブーブーしたら
ブーバー足りないですっ
逆にチップのソウルでちょっと釣りはいらねぇホッケかこつけたつもりが
バッグ
やられている食べないんですよね
難しいですよ
飲んじゃうかそんなん
そんな間違っこうしています
カッコルトっ
はいいた行ったポットまずええじゃんなーには入った子全部で
はずですけど俺っていう
これです
こんな絶対普通林など小多いお礼です
勝ちました皆さん砂糖塩見事に肇社長り
持った衣装
最初に3本柱から号ぜって言ってませんですか
入ってたっるっねあれこれやれやれ
これではこれ
井口が年にも同0
おおーー
[音楽]
bl
往生と編集必要でましたけどほんとなんか女なんだね
いやー楽しみあとたとさんずっと若干白トビしてるんで
治験ずっと美白に映っています bp 開くて何やってもあの俺は顔が浅いからそこれ
顔の彫りの浅さには定評があるのですか
ほとんどのんこのプラ棒に見えちゃう車大丈夫かな
俺ってわかる
マメだもんっ